hello everyone and welcome to another
video in our long awaited capablanca
saga we are back to the match josé raúl
capablanca vs. Frank James Marshall
we've already seen one game and it's a
game that kappa blanka himself chose for
his book my chest career here we're
gonna check another game I also want
that Capablanca included in his book so
for those of you I've seen as some of
you are following the series while
reading the book so I do hope you're
enjoying you know this part is well and
really a wonderful game that game 5 from
the from the previous video as we
already mentioned this match is
organized first eight victories and in
the first 5 games kappa blanka already
won two games so that's quite impressive
since this match was organized so Frank
Marshall could basically claimed the
title of US Champion after albeit three
years after the death of Harry Nelson
Pillsbury but so far he's not really
doing all that great down to 2-0 drawers
drawers non-count and capablanca again
has the white pieces and really I I
didn't know what the title this game so
chess is simple see you know yeah seems
perfectly fitting as kappa blanka also
mentions in his book that this is one
one of his better games against frank
marshall in this in this match so I do
hope you will enjoy it now let's check
it out Capablanca has the white pieces
and he opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and here comes the
Bishop to b5 so the real opus is on the
board we already mentioned that Lanka
did not study any theory one theory that
he did check was lost hers analysis of
f5 here in the rule opus but as black
plays d6 here the old Chinese defense a
couple long has really no Auto book here
completely and here we go c3 he mentions
that later he found out that d4 was the
appropriate response here based on the
theory back then but c3 is actually a
move prefered even even today so we
could say that he was definitely ahead
of his time Bishop to g4
already cap Ivanka mentions that the
bishop is misplaced here although for
the moment it the bishop does spend the
night but that's really really not
important here as the c3 pawn already
limits the d4 square from the night if
if the knight ever could get unpinned
there is a really no point in this pin
and the white will white will simply use
this Bishop to improve his position
similarly like if you remember in
Murphy's opera game where Bishop to g4
was played and then morphe basically
they used the bishop to create a very
powerful attack here couple uncle will
not well you'll just see how what
happens
d3 first by capablanca and now Bishop to
e7 and this is only move five but this
exact same position was never again
repeated up until today that I'm making
this video perhaps it was but not
anywhere in notable tournaments as this
position if you check any big database
is only available in this game
Capablanca versus marshal Knight bTW to
Capablanca is preparing after the skin
castles and the rook switches over to e1
to go Knight to f1 and then bring the
night over to e3 to force the bishop der
to retreat we have nice to have six
black keeps on developing once the
castle couple bunker castles and marshal
castles as well and here we have rook to
e1 and for those of you who are new to
new to this series new to chess in
general I have never heard of Frank
Marshall I once again do suggest you
check out Marshalls famous game the
American Beauty the link to it will be
the first thing we will see in the
description below just to get a general
idea of what kind of a fantastic
attacking player Frank Marshall was we
have h6 another moved at Kappa block
that doesn't really like he says that
it's it's a waste of time that there
there there's not much point to it so
nice to f1 black he goes knife to h7 I'm
making room for for the F pawn and now
comes Knights at e3
attacking the bishop and here kappa
blanka gives a very precise line you
have to retreat with the bishop of
course you could capture the knight but
then white will just be better with the
bishop pair but he gives if black
decides to go f5 which could have been
an initial plan by black defends the
bishop and offers a couple of trades
after it captures an f5 bishop
Knight captures rook captures the
deformer will be very strong and now a
white will always be better because as
capablanca gives the line you cannot
capture on d4 due to Bishop captures
pawn captures and now Knight captures on
d4 and there is attack on the roof
there's an attack on the c6 pawn which
will come as an attack on the Queen and
then the bishop the bishop is already
attacked and if you try something like
look to d5 you pin the night then queen
g4 comes why it starts a very strong
attack and all of the all of the threats
are still here so Marshall decides to
retreat we have burst up to h5 and now
comes a couple one has idea that he had
when he saw black's Bishop to g4 move
kappa blanka plays g4 and would this
move capablanca creates a very strong
outpost story very strong outpost for
his knight on f5 Bishop has to move we
have Bishop to g6 and now comes Knight
to f5 and okay now black can either
capture here with special characters to
remove the monster night but after G
captures with this beautiful strong
center a cover Blanca will simply play
King h1 play the roof to g1 and create a
very powerful attack against the black
king so after Knight to a5 black plays
h5 here couple Lanka says that again he
doesn't like this move because if the H
file is ever opened it will be only a
couple of longer that we'll be able to
use a th file and he simply plays h3 and
says okay what do you play now Marshall
decides to capture H cap first on g4 we
have H factors on g4 and now Bishop to
g5 it was about at this point that cup
of Lanka already says that he claims
that his position is winning and that
however black decides the play about
this game that he didn't think that it
was possible for Marshall to actually
save this game
Bishop to g5 was played with Knight
captures on g5 Knight captures on g5 and
now comes King to g2 Capablanca makes
room for his rook to come to h1 and
later he will be able to double rooks on
the H file we have d5 black wants to
open up the center I created an attack
against the white king and now Queen to
e2
black since the H file is now open
I will not gain all that much by opening
up the century upon characters then this
bishop can come to see for to be three
and be a very powerful attacking piece
against the black king who is over
already quite vulnerable
we have rook to e8 and now comes Luke to
h1 switching the roofs off to the h-file
rook to e6 bringing the rook to help out
with the defense and now comes Queen to
e3 with a double attack against the
night here and if you bring the Knights
to h7 it is possible but then white will
just continue in a similar fashion
Bishop to a4 Bishop to b3 and Popeil up
under d5 square and transfer the game
there here
marshal decides to go for f6 defending
in the night and g5 but capablanca
decides to go would do the same plan
Bishop today for transferring the Bishop
to b3 we have Knight to e7 and now
Russia back to b3 piling up like we said
on the d5 pawn and now the night helps
up with the defense of the point also
martial place c6 to bring another
defender to the d5 square Queen to g3
now with ideas of switching the Queen
over to the H file there you will have
some threats not immediate threats
against along the H file but you will
pressure the knight on d5 and black has
to do something about this first black
goes a 5 he wants to play a 4 and kick
this bishop off from this very strong
diagonal so Capablanca blocks it we have
a 4 and now comes Knight to f7 now a
couple of long Marshall will try to play
King f8 bring this Knight to the g8 and
then close off the position with 90 G to
H 6
so first Bishop to e3 Capablanca this
Bishop is still an active he wants to
activate it he wants to go Bishop to c5
to take hold of this powerful diagonal
as well and Marshall decides to prevent
this he plays b6 no Bishop to c5 for you
Capablanca and now comes a rook to h4
with the f6 pawn now here the rook will
be very safe on h4 and now the other
rook can also come to h1 it's a very
interesting how couple Lanka plays this
and how he makes it very simple he just
puts pieces on optimal squares and the
black is what is just suffocating
King 2f8 Marshall wants to run away with
his King also cause of the position with
the maneuver we mentioned an IT g8 to h6
rook a to h1 by cop Wonka and now comes
Knight to g8 and here we have Queen to
f3
now with further pressure of the d5 pawn
pretty much forcing wife to capture and
i-5 to relieve the pressure which
Marshall does with Bishop captures here
G captures here and now comes Luke to d6
the rook now moves and serves as further
protection of the d5 pawn but the
problem is the point from f5 now
controls the e6 Square and now the game
is simply lost for black Queen to h5
bringing the Queen into the attack going
for Quinta Queen to g6 and rook to h7 to
pile up on the g7 pawn black tries to
bring the rook into the defense rook to
a7 but now comes Queen to g6 as planned
and what do you play now as this is the
plan rook to a knife to h6 bringing the
knight from F to h6 blocking off the H
file but here it doesn't work so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find now everything is perfectly placed
you you cannot improve the position of
your pieces any further now it's time to
strike so feel free to pause the video I
will give you a couple of seconds as
usual find the move Capablanca played
and watch as blacks position
deteriorates in itself while I have a
nice tip of my water
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player pretty much a lot of things you
do are winning if you play Bishop
captures and h6 that is winning but it's
way cooler to play rook captures on h6
as it's you know seemingly giving up
some material for a powerful attack how
about the idea is pretty much the same
but if you have a the option in your own
games to either give up rook or a bishop
always give up the rook it's way cooler
so G captures on h6 otherwise you're
just down peace and now a bunch of
characters and h6 would check now the
problem is you cannot capture the bishop
because I have to look captures there's
really no defense against Brooke to h8
now whatever you play there's nothing
you can play to prevent this if you try
running away with the king with a king
is 7 you still get Queen g7 check King
moves in our case it will be checkmate
and any other form of defense that will
fail so Marshall decides not to capture
and he starts running away with the king
we have king to e7 but now first Queen
g7 check forcing the King back as the
pawn is protecting the e6 square we
already mentioned this King g8 and now
comes the Queen captures and g8 King to
d7 we have Queen to h7 check now either
the king will move and White will pick
up the rook here or you have to block
with the point so Queen blocks and now
we have Bishop to f8 forcing Marshall to
capture the Queen otherwise you're just
gonna face the row Queen captures here
so we have Queen captures on h7 rook
captures on h7 and now comes King to e8
you have to at least grab the bishop
you're gonna lose the rook on a 7 so
root cap person a 7 team captures on f8
and now comes King to f3 and it was in
this position on move 39 that Frank
James Marshall
resigned at the game this is only this
is only game 6 and cup of banca is
already three points in the lead so
really really just crushing this match
which which no money no one thought that
he was actually the favorite in so
that's quite impressive of course he
resigns as the Capablanca is now up a
full Bishop and when you think about it
Blanka even mentions that himself
other than the few a couple of moves in
the opening black didn't really do
anything all that wrong
he played admission up to G for move
which couple Monica said wasn't really
all that much and age six so two moves
that weren't mistakes or blunders they
were just kind of a waste of time and a
couple longer utilized this perfectly to
create this powerful attack and then
like we said blacks position just
deteriorated so he claims this to be one
of the better games of the match he
chose it for his book so I do hope you
enjoyed that I really think it's one of
the one of the beautiful things about
watching Capablanca games is that they
are so simple or rather he makes it seem
so simple Frank James Marshall in those
days was one of the strongest ten
players in the world and here couple on
Casas mmm-hmm
Bishop to g4 understand the sixth move I
don't know that's that's just not gonna
fly and he grazed this simplistic
masterpiece let's put it that way but
yeah like I said I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Alexander
Chernobyl skin a neighbor shamrock and
the Talbot
Hansel of Eric and Stephan McNally's for
a contribution to my channel thanks a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous video serie thank all for
watching and I will see you soon I will
definitely cover a few more games in
this match as they are quite fantastic
and then we are off to capo Blancas
first international tournament 1911 in
San sebastián Spain which is really a
clash of super players so I thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon